we now stand on the verge of victory and
I urge Congress to take us over the
finish line and send me a reform bill I
can sign into law Congress is about to
pass what's being called the biggest
financial sector reform package since
the Great Depression but the new regs
won't be any more effective than the
ones they replace and preventing the
next major panic for at least three
reasons I use turbotax repair to prepare
my returns they create a new watchdog
agency designed to protect consumers
from their own stupidity what that
really means is that you'll now be
facing fewer choices when it comes to
getting credit cards loans and doing
other basic financial transactions I use
TurboTax Rupert to prepare my returns
they replaced too big to fail with too
big to fail one of the major reasons why
financial institutions played Russian
roulette with the economy was because
they were betting they would get bailed
out which is precisely what happened the
new rules codify the idea that the
government will make sure certain
institutions can never fail and if you
think the big boys won't gain that
system then you don't understand how
well Citigroup Goldman Sachs and others
have come through the current melt at I
use TurboTax to prepare my returns the
financial crisis was set into motion by
government policies that encourage
people to buy homes they couldn't afford
at prices that were unsustainable
between desperate attempts to keep
people in houses and to keep interest
rates below an effective rate of zero
the government continues to pour more
money down that same rat hole markets
work best when the risk and reward
incentives are clear-cut when investors
know they really can lose it all they
act responsibly with their money if
regulators think they can create a
system that cushions us from bad
decisions and doesn't encourage bad
behavior it's a delusion will all be
paying for for a very long time for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie